jean-michel meurent au mondial c'est
celle où ça arrive un aveu d'échec total
du gouvernement c'est dire qu'ils
pataugent complètement sur la
connaissance du risque
parce que oui qu ils savent qui a aucun
risque est à ce point là on envoyait
tous les enfants oui sa paillasse
mangeant vois aucun enfant
c'est une précaution et quand mme à
lelystad or mais quand tu dis on peut
s'annoncer les mois à l'école
désolé moi ma fille et l'a pas baquet
chez les cruise je décroche on sait où
on bat donc peu par le relancer oui oui
valérie laurent sayeh porte qu'un ex
porte parole des républicains là
vraiment votre avis vous dire il
m'intéresse énormément là dessus écoutez
franchement quand on écoute est madame
pinatel qui mère des enfants
on ne rentrera plus jamais à l'école
parce que je suis désolé mais la réalité
c'est privé russie sera là en juin il
sera là on ne sait pas dans notre droit
donc bien sûr qu'il faut trouver des
solutions
est ce que dit valérie je ne comprends
mais ça c'est dans les familles où tout
va bien mais mettez-vous à la place mais
famille où il ya des grosses difficultés
déjà décidées pour ses propres enfants
éventuellement de les mettre en danger
ou pas c'est déjà une énorme
responsabilité
en plus les familles où les parents sont
séparés qui va prendre la décision avec
un enfer et enfin les enfants qui sont
déjà très absent de l'école dans des
familles où les enfants sont en échec
scolaire et qui voudront pas retourner à
l'école ça va être un enfer aussi la
devise républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité égalité c'est tous les
enfants à l'école en même temps on
adapte au départ avec des demi classe
oui mais l'obligation scolaire elle est
là et la france se doit de donner un
enseignement à tous une enfant de la
même façon qu'il a mais quoi qu'il
arrive quoi il ya un principe de réalité
de toute façon on n'avait pas lors des
rondes à l'étoile valérie oui mais moi
je dis russe khaled la même façon on a
compris que les enfants n'ont de toute
façon à part quelques cas
malheureusement terrible et bien sûr ne
sont pas malades
donc évidemment il faut qu'ils
retournent à l'école on ne peut pas
rester dans cette bulle en se disant
parce que j'ai les moyens de parler
calame et enfin donc c'est ok c'est pas
la réalité
il ya plein de bosses qui décroche il ya
plein de gosses je le redis j'ai dit
avant-hier j'ai c'est très important qu
il ya plein d'enfants maltraités et
d'être à la maison ça risque sur une
petit plus pour eux
donc s'il vous plaît allez à l'école ne
surveillait les bons soins sur les
enfants et le fait qu'ils soient pas en
danger et si vous entendez quoi que ce
soit à plus de 119 sophie koch non mais
moi j'ai trois enfants je vois pas en
quoi entre le 25 mai et le 30 juin
ils vont retourner à l'école pour faire
quoi en règle générale le dernier mois
d'abord il coûte rien d'abord on a eu
droit de retrait des professeurs là on
leur a dit attention droit de retrait ça
va être compliqué et il va pouvoir
falloir justifier de droit de retrait
ensuite on nous dit bon on met tous les
enfants à l'école avec effectivement
classe par classe etc
comment est-ce qu'on respecte la
distanciation sociale pendant la
récréation on peut pas y en avait 15 ans
sur les classes par sophie excusé mais
dès que l'on va faire
les enfants à l'école au film souvient
les points mais au fond de la sortie des
classes
non mais sophie pour 80 excusez-moi
souvenirs et je les aime énormément là
mais la question est claire c'est est ce
que vous comprenez la base du
volontariat bonne ou mauvaise idée
là vous mais pas répondu à la question
moi j'ai reçu un mail de l'école en me
disant ok donc ya le volet narnia mais
les enfants vont devoir suivre le
programme à la lettre mais comment bah
oui mais en fait on va recevoir les
cours il n'y a plus de vidéos zoom ça
sera plus dispensés par être désarmé
nous on va devoir le faire nous très
mauvaise idée très mal et gilles verdez
je n'arrive pas du tout à comprendre et
j'ai été extrêmement choqué mais petit
j'aime beaucoup ce qui vit valérie
benaïm parce que valérie les enfants qui
peuvent rester à la maison
s'il ya une continuité pédagogique
assuré l'équipe perd sa valérie mais oui
comment ils vont pouvoir
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir choisir et ce
sont des familles aisées ce sont les
familles privilégiées
ils peuvent aider leurs enfants toutes
les familles ou pauvre où il n'ya pas de
moyens ou y'a pas d'ordinateur ou les
parents ne peuvent pas aider n'y a pas
de continuité dont ils n'ont pas le
choix
les pauvres d'action ils sont obligés
d'aller à l'école et les régions droit
de choisir la société que vous
préconisez je suis pas du succès fois
vous c'est une société inégalitaire
belgique